all right we'll choose what you want to
do
or something
what do you what kind of movies do you
think i like
what do you see nobody at night this is
what okay at nights when we were
sleeping yeah she likes to sleep with
the ipad on
whatever watch she she drifts away she's
one of those that drifts away by
watching a show
yeah right
and so
and if i turn it off she'll wake up
and she'll do this she'll be she could
be snoring eyes back of her head right
and i'll sneak literally it'll take me
sometimes five minutes to slowly sneak
up without making any noise
just you know the tab on the top of the
ipad which is completely turns the
screen off right
as soon as i get like an inch toward it
she goes i'm watching
dude you have like legit yeah i'm
watching it
and her head was turned she was asleep
for an hour she wasn't right so it's
like i have to
listen
to the show that she's watching for
hours right it's a great show it's no
she's done that with the queen
that's the crown whatever the queen
crown right she's done it with um
what's the english island
love island love island yeah that's all
that and then you know what happens i've
moved on to an australian show called
offspring offspring but what happens is
she falls asleep to it but then the next
night
she has to watch it again because she
slept through it so i have to hear it
sometimes three or four or five times
you know i mean in a row falling asleep
in the same spot yeah yeah it's like i
started and sometimes when she plays
something i could recite the dialogue
yeah it's true yeah this is when this is
he says this because i've heard it so
many [ __ ] times but i have this thing
where it's like i don't know what it is
but i have um shame about falling asleep
and i don't know what happened in my
childhood but let's say for instance
like i'm falling asleep on a couch right
and sp like you and let's say you and
george are in the kitchen just fussing
about and you're having a conversation i
feel the need to prove to you that i'm
still awake so i will chime in on that
conversation
i'm asleep i'm asleep but i will say
things like uh-huh
all right yeah me too i thought that as
well like i have these built-in
mechanisms yeah to make it believe and
i'll have conversations with him
while he was watching what was it the
other day
when i was like falling asleep oh i was
watching something and she'll add on a
conversation she'll be asleep oh it was
in the car yesterday i was falling
asleep i didn't want you to know i was
falling asleep on the drive
and so he was listening to a crime
podcast and i'm able to be asleep but
still give input and feedback about what
he's listening to so that he won't know
that i'm actually like in a different
planet and i heard a snoring it's stupid
i don't snore i don't snore at all i've
never snored in my life you open your
mouth like this no i i'm a mouth asleep
whatever you guys seen that's good
lately
what have you watched lately george i've
been watching homeland and i hate watch
it so much because it's just so much of
the same
and the writing can sometimes just be so
obvious it's so like expositional let me
ask but then i get into it let me ask
you something i saw the first two
seasons of that thing okay
let me so it gets to the point where the
redheaded guy he comes back right yep
and then um he's obviously now
muslim